[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public c'est
parti pour 90 minutes de débats de
reportage et d'analyse grâce à nos
experts on donne du sens à l'actualité
tous les jours du lundi au jeudi à 18h
et 22h sur Public Sénat avec ce soir
deux grands thèmes d'actu l'armée
ukrainienne d'abord qui enchaîne les
victoires dans l'est du pays regagne
plusieurs axes de ravitaillement et
fragilise le président russe est-ce le
début de la fin pour Vladimir Poutine
l'homme qui tient la Russie depuis 23
ans peut-il perdre le pouvoir ce sera
notre premier débat juste après ces
titres et puis ensuite c'est une date
que je vous propose le 5 octobre
1972 ce jour-là Jean-Marie Le Pen crée
le Front national 5 décennies plus tard
il affirme que rien n'a changé
pour moi il y a rien de changé les
principes et les éléments de programme
sur les mêmes que ceux que je défendais
c'est un anniversaire embarrassant que
sa fille ne veut pas vraiment célébrer
mais que reste-t-il du FN du Front
national le logiciel idéologique a-t-il
changé quels sont les limites de sa
stratégie de normalisation réponse dans
45 minutes mais d'abord donc les détails
de la contre-offensive ukrainienne ces
derniers jours avec Samia de chien
chaque jour il reprenne un peu plus de
terrain dimanche les soldats ukrainiens
ont emporté une victoire de taille à
l'hymen un nœud ferroviaire stratégique
pour le ravitaillement de l'armée russe
depuis l'armée ukrainienne a reconqui
d'autres localités dans les régions de
Kerson et de kerkiv et compte bien
poursuivre sa contre-offensive dans les
quatre régions annexées par la Russie
ces territoires font partie de l'Ukraine
c'est notre terre je suis originaire de
la région c'est pour ça que je ne
m'arrêterai pas avant que le dernier
russe quitte cette terre
pour l'Ukraine l'enjeu et de progresser
le plus vite possible dans les régions
annexées par la Russie avant l'arrivée
de l'hiver car les conditions
météorologiques vont bientôt figer les
positions des deux camps
tout au long de cette semaine de
nouveaux drapeaux ukrainiens ont été
hissés dans le Dombasle il y en aura
encore plus dans une semaine
forcée de se replier vers l'Est l'armée
russe a reconnu une percée ukrainienne
qu'elle affirme avoir stoppé grâce à son
aviation le Kremlin doit reconstituer
ses forces et compte sur la mobilisation
partielle pour recruter 300 000
réservistes
depuis le 21 septembre une mobilisation
partielle est menée dans le pays à ce
jour plus de 200000 personnes ont
rejoint l'armée le Kremlin assure qu'un
nombre important de volontaires ce
serait présenté de même pour s'enrouler
mais plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'autres ont aussi quitté le pays pour
échapper à une mobilisation sur le front
ukrainien
est-ce le début de la fin pour Vladimir
Poutine voilà le thème de notre débat on
va l'analyser sur le plan militaire sur
le plan diplomatique et puis aussi en
interne à l'intérieur de la Russie et je
vous présente mes invités le général
Dominique trinquant bonsoir bienvenue
ancien chef de la Mission française
militaire militaire française à l'ONU à
lazareva bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
correspondante en France de
l'hebdomadaire
Ukraine ski this den le seul média
ukrainien avec une page en français
c'est important de le souligner Nicolas
Tenzer bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
aussi vous êtes enseignants en Sciences
Po Paris directeur du journal en ligne
d'escrucy et vous animez un blog sur les
questions internationales qui s'appelle
Tenzer stratégique et puis Laetitia
cruppetitorialiste politique bonsoir
Laetitia heureux de vous retrouver comme
comme chaque semaine peut-être la
question générale pour commencer on
rentrera vraiment dans le détail je l'ai
dit militaire diplomatique etc mais
est-ce que pour vous depuis un camp ce
mois de septembre marque je reprends la
question le début de la fin pour la
lumière Poutine oui un reversement de
situation très certainement
depuis le début de l'offensive d'abord à
Carson puis ensuite dans la région de
kerkiff on voit que l'armée ukrainienne
est passée à l'offensive depuis six mois
ça avait pas été le cas il y a eu des
petits contre-attaques à droite à gauche
mais là ce sont deux vrais offensives et
l'armée russe elle recule très nettement
dans la région de quartier nettement
depuis deux jours dans la région de
Kerson il y a une alerte il y a quelques
minutes on est en fin d'après-midi là 10
ans que selon les cartes russes il y a
un apport en recul de de l'armée russe
donc
même qu'il admettent exactement non
seulement c'est un renversement parce
que l'Ukraine est à l'offensive les
Russes reculent mais en plus les rues
les met ils le disent et de depuis
plusieurs jours on a beaucoup de
critiques sur les télévisions d'Etat
russe sur à la fois la mobilisation le
commandement l'armée etc etc beaucoup de
critiques qu'on entendait pas depuis 6
mois donc c'est assez étonnant
effectivement il y a un renversement en
situation on y reviendra on peut
imaginer juste que ces critiques sont
admises par le Kremlin et donc ils sont
font partie elles font partie de la
propagande ceci étant ça permet
d'éliminer j'allais dire des sous-fifs
ou des intermédiaires pour ne pas
attaquer directement le chef mais enfin
n'empêche que c'est une nouveauté ils le
font alors qu'ils ne le faisait pas
avant qu'il ne faisait pas auparavant
au-delà de la situation militaire à la
nazaréva est-ce qu'il y a des signes
d'un affaiblissement du pouvoir potinium
après vous ah je pense que oui parce que
justement il y avait cette critique qui
apparaissent et qui est nouveauté pour
la virus il y a aussi plein de gens qui
quittent le pays qui essayent de le
quitter ça aussi on ne voit que des
approuvent pas de cette façon la
politique des de le régime après on ne
va aussi que au Poutine n'arrive pas à
maîtriser ses propres troupes dans le
sens que il annonce les annexes de
région qui ne maîtrise pas ou chaque
fois
le territoire passe de plus en plus au
monde Ukrainiens qui qui doivent
récupérer leur terre donc c'est normal
mais voilà il y a les choses qui est
plusieurs signes qui montrent que ça va
pas dans le sens souhaité par Poutine
Nicolas Poutine le début de la fin je le
rappelle c'est le titre de ce débat
est-ce que ça doit être l'objectif de
l'Europe ça ma réponse c'est la fin du
pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine ma réponse
est clairement oui ça ne veut pas dire
qu'elles doivent être exprimées
évidemment tel quel par les dirigeants
européens on comprend que ce soit
extrêmement difficile mais il faut non
seulement que l'Ukraine gagne la guerre
mais aussi que le régime de Poutine la
paire de manière totale radicale entière
et définitive quand je dis le régime de
Poutine c'est bien sûr Poutine lui-même
mais ça pourrait être le cas échéant des
personnes qui lui ressemblent qui
auraient la même idée impérialiste de
conquête la même idéologie la même
volonté de déstabiliser les démocraties
des régions entières du monde regardez
ce qui se passe encore ces jours-ci en
Afrique par exemple de vouloir mettre la
main sur le Belarus qui est déjà
largement occupé par pas trop Prusse
avec le dictateur lucachenka qui en
boîte la main de Poutine regardez ce qui
se passe en Syrie vous avez toujours je
dirais des crimes massifs commis par
l'armée russe je pourrais multiplier les
exemples à Jeanne Birmann soutenu
également par la Russie enfin bon donc
je pense que en terme de sécurité
mondiale oui nous devons avoir
clairement cet objectif et après il
faudra mais c'est une autre tâche et une
autre paire de manches ça prendra du
temps faire en sorte que la Russie
future devienne un pays normal et
démocratique ce n'est pas gagné d'avance
mais ça ça s'impose pas de l'extérieur
chaque étape en son temps mais je pense
que bien sûr nous devons avoir cet
objectif je voudrais on va analyser
évidemment plusieurs séquences ensemble
on a une que vous avez tous vu à la mort
du week-end dernier parce que c'était
vendredi ce concert sur la plage rouge
pour célébrer l'annexion de territoire
dans les quatre régions ukrainiennes je
mets des guillemets à tout ça et on a
choisi un extrait voilà ce que déclare
le président russe
nous sommes devenus plus forts parce que
nous sommes ensemble la vérité et de
notre côté et le pouvoir réside dans la
vérité cela signifie la victoire la
victoire sera à nous
[Applaudissements]
les Ukrainiens ont-ils reçu ces images
de la place rouge
parce que ça nous rappelle beaucoup le
discours des Brejnev on se dit qu'on ne
prend la machine de temps et qu'on ne
revienne dans le passé avec donc ce
président de russe on ne considère
Poutine une mauvais perdant qui ne sait
pas reconnaître ses propres défaites et
prêtes à sacrifier les dizaines des
milliers de vie uniquement pour ne pas
reconnaître cet or et aussi entraîner
son pays dans un désastre donc en gros
on n'a pas peur de Poutine on a on est
très critique vis-à-vis de lui depuis
très longtemps et on n'a pas peur des
semenaces non plus comment il faut
analyser je reviens vers vous Nicolas
Tenzer ce pseudos référendum est-ce
qu'il faut leur donner de l'importance
ma réponse est non c'est référendum ne
change rien ils ont été déclarés
illégaux par l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale on voit d'ailleurs que il
concerne des zones qui sont d'ailleurs
en partie quand même
évidemment contrôle heureusement de
l'Ukraine et ça change absolument rien
ni d'un point de vue ukrainien ni d'un
point de vue occidental il est
parfaitement clair qu'il va falloir
reconquérir intégralement ces
territoires d'ailleurs même le président
de la République le disait il y a peu de
temps il disait il a réaffirmé
l'intégrité territoriale de l'ensemble
du territoire
ukrainien ce qui signifie aussi la
Crimée annexé depuis 2014 et je crois
qu'il est très important de ne pas faire
de différence dans les territoires qui
ont été récemment annexés et la Crimée
et je pense que d'ailleurs d'une
certaine manière c'est très simple
annexion montre que tous les discours
qui disaient oui mais la Crimée c'est
une ligne rouge c'est différent etc non
absolument pas ça fait partie du
territoire ukrainien c'est très
important de le réaffirmer
2050 est-ce qu'on peut en creux se dire
que ces référendum c'est pas justement
une marque de faiblesse
de fuite en avant bien sûr alors il faut
rappeler que c'est référendum devaient
avoir lieu début septembre puis novembre
pion était de façon très précipité à une
semaine avant
à la semaine dernière et on s'était une
réponse à de première défaite militaire
on peut dire en quelque sorte
l'impression que ça donnait c'est vite
on les déclare en excès avant qu'on ne
reprenne tout quoi parce que les
offensives étaient en cours donc c'est
effectivement une une preuve de
faiblesse les discours de vendredi avec
les deux discours l'un vers la
gouvernance russe rassemblée dans la
place Saint-Georges dans la salle
Saint-Georges pardon tout le monde était
là aux ordres et ensuite sur la place ou
en fait les gens avaient été convoqués
et c'est une espèce de mobilisation que
veut donner le président Poutine avec
sur le discours dans la salle Saint-Jean
ça m'a frappé une petite partie sur
l'annexion et puis un grand discours en
fait sur la guerre des civilisations sur
l'offensive qu'il veut lancer parce
qu'il voit bien que sur le terrain il
est en train de perdre et de la guerre
des civilisations en fait c'est à
s'adresser à ces pseudo alliés qui
n'accepte même pas l'annexion je veux
parler de la Chine je parlais de l'Inde
je parlais de la Turquie qui eux aussi
refusent l'annexion ils l'ont dit alors
on les amène sur un autre terrain
l'ennemi c'est l'Occident les puissances
aussi à la limite les concerts en
particulier la Chine donc donc c'est il
se met à l'offensive parce qu'en fait il
est obligé de se défendre je reste avec
vous parce que on l'a entendu dans le
dans le sujet Samia dechire tout à
l'heure ce bon le ministre de la Défense
russe qui caffirme avec moi avoir
mobilisé 200 000 soldats sur les 300000
qui étaient attendus alors là je suis
vraiment sur la situation militaire
est-ce qu'ils peuvent changer la donne
c'est c'est renfort alors non pour
plusieurs raisons la première raison
c'est que le président Poutine a lancé
une
demi-mesure qui est la mobilisation
partielle où il dit 300 000 et sous
l'article 7 du décret qui était camouflé
on n'avait pas vu mais qui a fûté c'est
pas 300000 mais c'est un million d'eux
et ceci fait la fait suite à un appel à
volontariat ça veut dire que l'appel à
Valentinien n'a pas donné ce qu'il
fallait donc on est obligé de mobiliser
et quand on mobilise partiellement on ne
satisfait pas les radicaux qui
demandaient une mobilisation totale et
on ne satisfait pas naturellement ceux
qui sont ciblés qui ont pour la majeure
partie d'entre eux pas très envie d'y
aller deuxièmement point une
mobilisation comme ça faut rappeler que
la mobilisation le pendant c'est la
mobilisation ukrainienne dès le départ
de la guerre donc il y a 6 mois donc là
vous avez le temps de préparer les gens
et on voit les offensives aujourd'hui
les offensives c'est pas des gens qui
étaient sur la première ligne sont des
gens qui ont été formés et équipés
derrière préparer pour passer à
l'offensive là le problème c'est que les
les réservistes qu'on appelle on va les
jeter dans la fournaise au fur et à
mesure et au passage parlez-moi d'être
trivial mais les anciens qui combattent
depuis six mois ils vont voir arriver
ceux qui n'ont pas combattu et vont leur
dire mon coco moi j'ai sauvé ma peau
pendant 6 mois maintenant c'est à toi tu
passes devant vous voyez l'ambiance dans
les unités ça va pas être terrible parce
que il n'a pas le temps de faire ce
qu'on fait les Ukrainiens de former des
unités puis organiser commander ils ont
perdu vous savez que le défaut de
l'armée russe c'est qu'il y a très peu
de sous-officiers donc ils ont perdu
beaucoup d'officiers qui ont été obligés
de se porter en avant et donc dans le
commandement aujourd'hui ils ont un
problème majeur c'est qu'il manque
énormément d'encadrement et donc si nous
pas les unités les formes et les
envoient j'allais dire commander groupés
etc bah ils envoient des gens au fur et
à mesure et qui vont être pris dans le
chaudron comme on dit et justement
est-ce que le nombre de morts qui
étaient un tabou jusqu'à maintenant
commence à être dévoilé le nombre de
morts côté russe évidemment il y a des
indices vous savez qu'il y a eu des
images assez frappantes de mer qui
allait parler à des policiers et qui
leur disaient vous nous mentez c'est
nous qui avons attaqué l'Ukraine c'est
pas l'Ukraine etc c'était dans quoi dans
les régions pauvres de Russie et les
régions pauvres se sont celles qui ont
déjà donné des soldats et là dans la
mobilisation leur dit il faut encore en
donner et vous imaginez dans les
familles où ils ont pas vu revenir un ou
deux fils on dit en ça va pas envoyer le
troisième c'est pas possible d'où la
réaction de kadirof d'ailleurs qui lui
envoie ses fils ah oui il a annoncé ça
j'ai compris des gamins de 14 ans
je sais pas quel père peut prendre cette
décision là vous lis intervenir
d'abord il y a aussi la question de
l'équipement c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui
quand même l'équipement je dirais n'est
pas je dirais de première qualité il y a
des difficultés pour avoir des pièces
détachées ça je pense que c'est un
facteur important et puis surtout je
pense que une armée ça se prépare très
longtemps à l'avance quand on voit tout
le travail de transformation par exemple
que les armées de l'OTAN ont fait ça a
duré des années et aujourd'hui on a
quand même une armée russe qui est
relativement sclérosée dans ses
habitudes ces méthodes de commandement
ces marges de manœuvre qui a une très
mauvaise connexion entre ces différents
éléments terrestres maritimes et aériens
très mauvaise information qui passe etc
et donc ça on ne voit pas comment
j'avais même le type de commandement on
ne voit pas comment tout ceci en trois
mois ou en six pourrait être amélioré
devant au contraire une armée
ukrainienne extrêmement intelligente
mobile subtiles qui a une pensée
stratégique et je pense qu'on a vraiment
d'ailleurs deux systèmes le système
russe qui se fissure de toute part
l'armée mais aussi les hôpitaux l'école
les infrastructures la recherche et puis
un pays qui est un pays extrêmement
dynamique et je crois que le contraste
entre les deux systèmes n'a jamais été
aussi parlant oui on pourrait dire qu'il
y a une double surprise c'est à la fois
la qualité de de l'armée ukrainienne et
puis la faiblesse de de l'armée russe si
on doit un peu analyser ce qui se passe
depuis la modernisation de l'armée russe
et en fait
sans oublier que l'armée ukrainienne
n'est pas seule oui à l'envers on va on
va écrire américain aussi bien dans le
renseignement dans l'équipement que dans
la préparation de l'opération et
gigantesque on y reviendra évidemment je
voudrais rester sur le l'armée russe et
donc c'est alors 300 000 peut-être un
million d'euros vous nous disiez nouveau
soldats attendus il y a ses avocats
russes qui se disent submergés par des
demandes d'aide de la part de ceux qui
cherchent à échapper justement à la
mobilisation alors on regardait je vous
propose à découvrir c'est un un avocat
qui s'appelle Serge a écrivainco il
dirige citizen armylo c'est un groupe de
défense des droits de l'Homme composé
d'une dizaine d'avocats ça existe encore
en Russie nous travaillons 24 heures sur
24 ceux qui viennent nous voir sont
paniqués ils ne comprennent pas ce qui
se passe il immobilise n'importe qui et
la loi les autistes les autorises à
recruter n'importe qui à lazareva
qu'est-ce qu'on sait justement du moral
de ces renforts et puis du mouvement
vous l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à
l'heure du mouvement pour y échapper la
mobilisation l'armée elle a annoncé que
il y a ouvert deux lignes de téléphone
où les gens qui ne veulent pas se battre
mais qui peuvent pas échapper à la
mobilisation peuvent se rendre en bonne
condition donc il y a les garanties que
ils se rendent pas rendus à la Russie si
ils ne veulent pas selon la convention
de Genève ou sinon ils peuvent être
échangés
donc parce que bon il y a aussi beaucoup
de prisonniers pris par l'armée russe et
on ne veut récupérer nos gens donc il y
a cette option là et ce que je sais que
c'est deux lignes sont saturées que
vraiment 24 heures sur 24 il y a des
gens qui s'adressent et qui veulent ne
pas mourir n'est pas tuer et échapper à
cette bande de sang
en Russie cette mobilisation c'est de
l'improvisation de la désorganisation et
du mensonge improvisation parce que
l'armée russe a été réorganisée en 2008
depuis il y a eu aucun exercice de
mobilisation la mobilisation ça
s'improvise pas il faut la préparer d'où
la désorganisation le président Poutine
a été obligé de sortir trois décrets
après le fameux décret de mobilisation
pour expliquer que les étudiants qui
avaient déjà été mobilisés ne devaient
pas être mobilisés enfin pour clarifier
les choses quoi donc c'est c'est
vraiment complètement désorganisé et le
mensonge j'en parlais on dit 300 000 en
fait c'est un million d'eux mais
pourquoi pour essayer d'en avoir 300 000
parce que c'est tellement mal leur
mobilisation et alors on vous mélange
tout et on vous dit tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs on protège vous disiez et ben
en fait il y a beaucoup de volontaires
attendez si c'est de la mobilisation
vous avez pas besoin de volontaire et si
c'est des volontaires vous avez pas
besoin de mobilisation vous voyez il y a
un mélange absolument complet qui marque
la très grande désorganisation depuis le
début pour cette opération de l'armée
russe pour une raison simple c'est que
l'opération le 24 février c'était
quelque chose qui devait se passer en
trois jours par surprise parce que les
Ukrainiens d'ailleurs il y avait un
appel soldat ukrainien rendez-vous c'est
pas la peine rejoignez nos lignes et il
y a eu un échec complet et là l'armée
russe a dû organiser une véritable
opération or la rigidité du système
russe fait sur le plan stratégique qu'il
a fallu trois mois pour retrouver
innover une opération qui se concentre
sur le bombasse et maintenant sur le
plan tactique quand l'imam dit il faut
les con décroche le Kremlin lui dit non
tenez quand personne dit il faut qu'on
décroche on va être il y a quand même
10000 soldats qui restent d'être
prisonniers là-dedans et bien euh au
Kremlin on dit non tenez c'est leur
Stalingrad Carson donc ça veut dire on
tient jusqu'au bout mais actuellement à
l'évidence sur le terrain on voit bien
que ça ne tient pas la route alors le
soutien à l'Ukraine le soutien de la
France de de l'Europe à l'Ukraine c'est
le thème du c'était le thème du premier
débat hier en ouverture en reprise de la
session parlementaire à l'Assemblée
Laetitia et on va faire un focus sur ça
va nous ouvrir un peu le champ
diplomatique on va dire dans ce débat
sur le le discours de la première
ministre Elisabeth borde car pointé le
positionnement flou du rassemblement
national et de la France insoumise sur
l'aide à l'Ukraine justement c'est
encore un peu plus subtil que cela
Thomas parce qu'elle n'a cité ni les uns
ni les autres mais elle a tourné la tête
à droite vers Marine Le Pen puis à
gauche ensuite vers les députés de la
France insoumise je vous propose de
revoir cet extrait
les Russes misaient sur notre peur et
notre division
l'Union européenne a montré qu'elle
était forte et savait réagir l'Europe
n'a pas reculé devant les décisions
courageuses je pense notamment à
l'embargo sur les importations de
charbon de pétrole brut et de produits
raffinés russes
et ses sanctions n'en déplaisent à ceux
qui massent que leur fascination pour
l'impérialisme russe par un prétendu
patriotisme elle fonctionne
le petit regard effectivement
voilà le message était très clair en
fait l'exécutif tente de pointer
l'irresponsabilité à la fois du
rassemblement national et de la France
insoumise dans leur prise de position
depuis le début de la guerre en Ukraine
Elizabeth borne et même aller assez loin
parce que elle a dit que il y avait des
accointances de ces deux parties avec la
Russie de Vladimir Poutine
contre la Russie fonctionnent mais il y
a aussi dans ces propos d'isabeth borne
un message on va dire de politique
intérieure à destination des Français et
oui puisque c'est toujours l'opinion
publique qui est visée dans un discours
politique et l'opposition la elle aussi
bien compris elle a l'opinion publique
dans son viseur écoutait la réaction de
Marine Le Pen c'était ce matin sur BFM
TV non seulement ça ne fonctionne pas
mais de surcroît ça sanctionne les
Français nous allons avoir un hiver
difficile et peut-être prochain encore
plus difficile que celui-ci et ce sera
de la responsabilité de ceux qui ont
pris des décisions qui étaient des
décisions non réfléchies ces sommes
toutes assez binaires le gouvernement
dit les sanctions fonctionnent il faut
sauvegarder la démocratie et donc notre
modèle français et donc sauver et
protéger nos compatriotes quand le RN et
LFI disent que finalement c'est que son
son ne servent à rien et qu'au contraire
elle provoque chez nous la crise
énergétique donc je ne dis pas que la
guerre en Ukraine est instrumentalisée à
des fins de propagande intérieure mais
c'est vrai que ce sujet créé chez nous
une ligne de fracture dans la classe
politique et l'enjeu c'est de savoir de
quel côté va pencher l'opinion publique
Nicolas Tenzer le président par intérim
du rassemblement national Jordan
Bardella menacé de faire condamner ce
qui insinue que le RN a des liens avec
la Russie alors ça a provoqué un mot
dièse un hashtag viral sur les médias
sociaux grosso modo où tout le monde
reprenait cette formulation vous lui
dites chiche d'une certaine façon oui
bien sûr je veux dire il est
parfaitement évident que le lien entre
le rassemblement national et la Russie
était établi il était établi depuis
longtemps non seulement avec le prêt
bancaire accordé par une banque russe à
travers un certain nombre je dirais de
discours quand même 13 anciens pour ceux
qui suivent le sujet depuis longtemps du
rassemblement national vous aviez évoqué
la sanction et les protestations contre
les sanctions soi-disant le mal que ça
faisait aux Français moi je les ai déjà
entendu avec les sanctions pourtant
beaucoup plus légères en 2014
rappelez-vous les sanctions
doubleurstensions financières je dirais
à propos de l'envahissement du Damba
c'est la non-application des accords de
Minecraft personnel avec la Crimée on
avait déjà des protestations de tous
ceux qui défendaient soi-disant la
Russie on voyait parfaitement d'où ça
venait et on l'a vu aussi d'ailleurs un
certain nombre d'industriels on voyait
la Chambre de commerce encore russe etc
dont le dans le directeur d'ailleurs
revient d'acquérir la nationalité russe
voilà quel est l'intérêt pour le
rassembler tout simplement je pense que
c'est un intérêt d'abord idéologique
c'est le culte de l'homme fort peut-être
évidemment y a-t-il autre chose derrière
on sait quand même on a eu quand même ce
rapport je dirais on reconnaît pas
encore toute la teneur du renseignement
américain qui disait qu'il y avait eu
plus de 300 millions d'euros ce qui
paraît quand même un peu faible
c'est la fourchette basse voilà
fourchette basse voilà en direction des
parties européens essentiellement
semble-t-il d'extrême droite un peu
d'extrême gauche aussi 24 pays 24 pays
concerts
et il suffit encore une fois de lire
l'ensemble des déclarations de l'extrême
droite rassemblement national ou autre
c'était aussi le cas de monsieur Zemmour
d'ailleurs pour voir encore une fois que
la complaisance est claire jamais ils
n'ont dénoncé les crimes de guerre les
crimes contre l'humanité de Poutine ni
en Ukraine ni en Syrie ils ont toujours
demandé à ce qu'on réhabilite le régime
comme ça de qu'on s'engage avec la
Russie davantage je veux dire il y a
tous les éléments encore une fois les
faisceaux d'indices convergent
évidemment dans ce sens alors je disais
que ça ouvrait un chapitre diplomatique
et je me tourne vers vous Dominique
trinquant parce que vous connaissez bien
et pourquoi je le fonctionnement de
l'ONU vous êtes venu sur ce plateau il y
a quelques semaines c'était au moment de
la 77e assemblée générale des Nations
unies à New York quel bilan vous en
faites finalement est-ce qu'elle a
marqué un isolement renforcé de Vladimir
Poutine ou pas forcément alors je pense
que la dernière résolution qui a été
votée vendredi sous président françaises
a marqué l'isolement très nettement
il n'y a eu qu'un vote contre c'est le
vote russe il y a eu quatre votes
d'abstention et 10 votes pour donc c'est
quand même au Conseil de sécurité à
l'assemblée générale je vais vous dire
j'ai été très déçu par le discours du
président Zelinski le président Zelinski
avait un boulevard devant lui il
suffisait qu'il s'adresse à tous les non
online movement les
souligner ancien pays de colonisé en
disait mais regardez c'est une guerre
coloniale venez avec nous qui sommes
sous le jour d'un colonisateur qui
s'appelle la Russie et en fait il s'est
cantonné dans l'attaque frontale du
président Poutine pour aller devant les
tribunaux ce qui était vraiment pas le
sujet donc je pense qu'il a raté quelque
chose je vais vous dire pourquoi parce
que comme vous le disiez je connais bien
l'assemblée vous avez cette assemblée
avec 193 pays déjà la première chose
qu'il faut observer qui c'est qui est
présent qui est physiquement
physiquement présent déjà si la salle
est pleine c'est déjà pas mal ça veut
dire que les gens sont en bas et à la
fin quelle est la réaction on
s'applaudit on se lève on se lève pas
etc et là il a eu un résultat très très
mitigé et je crois que c'est parce qu'il
a raté l'impact de ce discours alors que
c'était le moment pour le faire mais
mise à part ça je pense que maintenant
aux Nations Unies il y a de plus en plus
de pays qui étaient disons qui disait
c'est pas notre guerre c'est neutre tout
ça on va voir etc et on s'aperçoit que
finalement les seuls qui soutiennent
vraiment aujourd'hui c'est la Corée du
Nord la Syrie peut-être le Venezuela je
vais pas regarder mais Nicaragua
également mais très très peu très très
peu de vrais soutiens alors maintenant
il faut pas se leurrer le discours je
reviens au discours de Poutine de
vendredi le discours de vendredi à
Poutine donc sur la Place Rouge celui
dont on parle surtout celui qui a eu
dans la salle Saint-Georges dans
laquelle en fait il s'adresse aux gens
qui disent et beaucoup de pays le disent
dans le monde les Occidentaux arrêtaient
de nous donner des leçons arrêtez de
nous imposer vos règles nous on n'est
pas comme ça on n'est pas vous comprenez
alors il a il est il a en plus là il
s'est adressé directement à nos parties
parce que quand il a dit il y aura pas
en Russie de parents 1 et de parents
d'eux de changement de sexe et tout il a
regardé il a regardé ce qui se passe
chez nous très clairement donc je pense
que là il s'est lancé dans cette
offensive pour aller sur un autre
terrain parce que il se rend bien compte
que l'annexion le territoire tout ça en
revanche ça va pas marcher alors il y a
un levier évident d'affaiblissement du
pouvoir de Vladimir Poutine c'est celui
des sanctions et je propose à Steve
Jourdain de nous rejoindre bonsoir Steve
bienvenue pour faire alors on sait on
s'est concentré sur les sanctions de
l'Union européenne oui on en est à 7 7 3
sanctions a été décidée depuis le mois
de février et l'invasion de l'Ukraine
parmi ces sanctions retrouvent notamment
un embargo sur l'essentiel du pétrole et
du charbon russe l'exclusion de
plusieurs banques russes du système
d'échange switch la fermeture de
l'espace aérien des ports et des routes
de l'Union européenne à l'aviation au
bateau et au transporteur russe il y a
aussi le gel des avoirs de la Banque
centrale russe hors de Russie un embargo
sur leur russe ou encore le gel des
avoirs de Vladimir Poutine et de l'égard
que russe voilà pour les principales
sanctions décider jusque là par l'Union
européenne mais l'Union européenne va
aller plus loin en réaction à l'annexion
des territoires
Ukrainiens la semaine dernière la
Commission a présenté en septembre un
huitième paquet de sanctions au menu
notamment de nouvelles interdictions
d'importation de produits russes dans
l'Union européenne une extension du
nombre de produits dont l'exportation
vers la Russie est prohibé ou encore un
allongement de la liste des
personnalités russes sanctionnées est-ce
que c'est sanctions fonctionnent c'était
l'objet d'une passe d'armes Laetitia en
parler hier d'une tasse d'amis hier à
l'Assemblée nationale un débat sur
l'Ukraine était organisé et Elisabeth
borne a assuré que la méthode choisie
était la bonne écoutée là objectif est
le même depuis le début
rendre le coup de la guerre
insupportable pour la Russie frapper
durement son économie pour l'empêcher de
financer son offensive
nous avons pris des sanctions massives
et de tous les ordres des sanctions
financières qui limitent les capacités
de financement de l'État russe et des
entreprises une position qui n'est pas
partagée par le rassemblement national
le parti de Marine Le Pen considère que
ses sanctions sont inefficaces écoutez
la politique de sanction sur les
produits énergétiques n'a pas produit
les fruits attendus la Russie n'a pas
renoncé et les exportations de
combustibles fossiles de la Russie
s'élèvent à 158 milliards d'euros sur
les premiers mois de la guerre dans les
faits qu'on regarde de près les
sanctions fonctionnent bel et bien à
condition et bien de considérer que ces
sanctions visent à paralyser l'industrie
militaire rue sur ce point Moscou qui
importe un des semis conducteurs pour
fabriquer certaines armes à dû
reconnaître dernièrement que le pays
avait 15 ans de retard en la matière et
qu'il était actuellement en pénurie de
composants conséquences concrets sur le
terrain Thomas plusieurs usines
notamment de missiles sont actuellement
complètement à l'arrêt merci Steve
Jordan Nicolas Tenzer sur cet aspect
peut-être militaire pour pour commencer
il y a un effet des sanctions qui est
évident dans dans la faiblesse de
l'armée russe on parlait le général
traducteur absolument donc là c'est
sûrement les sanctions marches elles
fonctionnent parce que effectivement on
le voit les les avions russes de chasse
ne peuvent plus recevoir un certain
nombre de composants qui a une pénurie
massive d'armement donc c'est quelque
chose qui fonctionne maintenant si on
prend l'ensemble des sanctions y compris
sur l'alimentation financière de
l'effort de guerre là on a effectivement
peut-être quelques problèmes le premier
c'est bien sûr que vous avez un certain
nombre de pays qui contournent les
sanctions notamment la Chine notamment
la Russie sur le plan financier
également les ebirs Arabes Unis il y en
a quelques autres aussi qu'on pourrait
mentionner et donc ça ça fait que la
Russie dispose toujours d'un trésor de
guerre ce qui pose une vraie question
d'ailleurs pour les pays occidentaux qui
sont en lien avec ces pays et pour
certains avec lesquels il y a des
accords des traités
est-ce que nous
occidentaux de manière nécessairement
discrète ça n'a pas être public
pouvons-nous convaincre ces pays de
renoncer à contourner cet effort de
guerre on notera par exemple que la
Turquie a commencé quelle assez retiré
du système mire qui a un système de
transaction de paiement et donc elle a
commencé je dirais à avoir une attitude
de disons plus raisonnable dans sa
politique à l'égard de la Russie
maintenant troisième élément quand même
on peut dire que ces sanctions elles
sont très bien elles sont très bonnes
beaucoup plus fortes qu'en 2014 mais
qu'on doit passer au huitième train de
sanction demain peut-être 9e dixième
montre qu'on n'a pas frappé très fort
assez vite je donnerai que deux exemples
d'abord il y a un certain nombre de
banques ça a été rappelé qui ne sont pas
actuellement bancrusse qui ne sont pas
actuellement sous sanctions deuxièmement
il y a un certain nombre de ligarques ou
de personnes qui sont en quelque sorte
l'épine dorsale du Kremlin et il y avait
une liste qui avait été de ce point de
vue là émises par l'association
anticorruption créée par le dissident
russe en prison Alexa inavalli qui
disait il y a 6000 personnes qui doivent
être sanctionnées
est loin de ces 6000 personnes y compris
juste procureur journaliste voilà mais
sanctionne sur les interdictions de
voyager gel des avoir à l'étranger
interdiction pour les enfants par
exemple d'aller faire des études dans
des pays européens aux États-Unis je
pense que ça c'est évidemment important
et troisième élément très rapidement on
voit par exemple certaines sociétés y
compris en France ou dans des pays
européens qui continuent des sociétés
des filiales nationales européennes de
société russes qui continuent à recevoir
un certain nombre de financements
indirects de la Russie donc il y a un
vrai problème d'application d'un certain
nombre de sanctions et je pense que ce
sont des sujets sur lesquels
effectivement les européens devront
travailler encore plus je vois qu'on
parle à l'instant vous l'avez évoqué
rapidement tout à l'heure mais de la
stratégie ou de l'action de volodières
zalenski parce que c'est vrai que on est
focalisé beaucoup sur la sur la Russie
et que les prises de parole de
volodières zenki on peut avoir le
sentiment qu'elle se répète un peu
quelle là c'est un peu comment vous
analysez vous sa stratégie et notamment
ça stratégie de mobilisation de nos
opinions publiques
occidentales est-ce qu'elle continue de
de fonctionner d'une certaine façon
cette stratégie d'après mais ça c'est
difficile pour moi d'évaluer à quel
point ça fonctionne par contre je dois
quand même dire que zelinsky il est
peut-être le premier dirigeant on passe
seulement un craignant qui s'adresse
systématiquement régulièrement et sans
arrêt à tous les parlements au
gouvernement aux différents assemblées
certes les certains de discours sont
plus réussis les autres moindres réussis
quelquefois c'est bien ciblé quelquefois
moins bien ciblesse certainement qui
peut avoir ses erreurs aussi mais je
pense que ça pique beaucoup et qu'il
amène beaucoup de son expérience en fait
de la vie avant qu'il est rentré en
politique parce que c'est une
communicant cette personne on l'a
suffisamment raconté voilà donc c'est ce
qu'il sait faire il sait parler aux gens
il s'est trouvé le mot très simple et je
pense aussi que si on parle de l'impact
pour la société ukrainienne il est
soutenu il parle avec les paroles qui
touchent les gens et je pense que son
soutien c'est quelque chose comme 90%
actuellement c'est énorme en fait vu que
le pays de guerre vu que les gens sont
tristes beaucoup et il y a pourquoi
malgré ça souvent on a la tendance à
rapporter tous ces frustrations sur le
pouvoir je pense que tous les peuples
sont pareils dans cette façon de voir
les choses et là quand même malgré ça il
est il est soutenu
je voudrais que vous détailler ce que
vous aviez commencé à dire tout à
l'heure c'est le moment de nous donner
vraiment plus d'informations là-dessus
sur le l'ampleur du soutien américain
parce qu'on dit il y a les armes il y a
les livraisons d'armes mais c'est
beaucoup plus que ça c'est bien plus que
ça bon c'est leur enseignement d'abord
c'est la formation depuis 2014 les
Américains et les Britanniques en
particulier ont été présents en Ukraine
et ont formé la mécanienne depuis 2014
soit en Ukraine soit aux États-Unis soit
en Angleterre et il continue il y a
toujours des soldats
Ukrainiens qui sont formés en
Grande-Bretagne 10000 à peu près en ce
moment ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est le si vous voulez
quand vous avez le renseignement
américain il y a une vingtaine de
satellites à peu près qui observent
partout l'électronique l'optique etc ça
donne une information de première main
qui est facile et puis la préparation
des offensives les deux offensives
Carson car kiffent qui ont été vous en
souvenez moi je me souviens sur les
plateaux télévisés les les journalistes
étaient choqués en disant mais on peut
pas avoir d'informations on peut pas y
aller je dis c'est normal c'est la
guerre c'est pas votre rôle d'y aller
bon évidemment je comprends que le
journaliste est en vie d'y aller mais
c'était le blackout complet et en
revanche il y a eu préparation voire
répétition des opérations et les
opérations on le voit débouche et des
bouches bien et des bouches au bon
endroit avec une manœuvre assez simple
vous savez en termes militaire fixé
déborder on fixe à Kerson et d'un seul
coup vous avez les Russes qui voient ça
qui envoient des troupes quasiment de la
première armée de la garde et première
troupe pour aller à Carson le trou
secret
ils attaquent dans la région de
de l'image enfin qui débouche à l'imam
mais le la région du Nord pourquoi parce
que les Russes avaient dégarni et à ce
moment-là l'opération elle progresse à
Carson et là depuis deux jours on est en
train de voir que comme ils ont coupé la
logistique depuis longtemps avec les
imars qui servent à ça en fait à taper
loin pour taper tous les no logistiques
et la logistique qui vont à 80 km et qui
sont extrêmement précis et bien il coupe
la logistique donc les Russes qui
reposent sur le nombre d'obus à envoyer
par jour bah en nombre moitié ou un
quart et n'y arrive plus et il commence
à être enfermé dans Kerson également
donc c'est une manœuvre qui est bien
montée de toute point de vue du
renseignement de la manœuvre et des feux
mais vous l'avez dit vous-même c'est
très difficile pour des journalistes
occidentaux d'aller vérifier par
eux-mêmes donc comment peut-on donner
ces informations là elle nous elle nous
arrive de l'armée ukrainienne et il nous
invite aussi avoir une
[Musique]
et ce qui a permis aux Ukrainiens en
particulier puisqu'il parlait le même
Rome de rentrer dans les réseaux alors
qu'on prend le Russe on a un autre
langue
russe et donc qui était capable de qui
était capable de la crise et qui souvent
on fait le choix d'arrêter de parler
russe d'ailleurs dès le début du conflit
alors la dernière fois qu'on a eu un
débat sur le crâne sur plateau vous nous
avez dit de pas sûr estimer la menace
nucléaire mais bon je vais je vais quand
même l'évoquer parce que depuis il y a
eu ces prises de parole notamment du
président de tchétchène dans la cité
tout à l'heure
Ramzan Kadirov il y a aussi l'ancien
chef de l'État l'ancien Premier ministre
aussi russe Mitry Medvedev qui ont d'une
certaine façon souhaitée à Nicolas
Tenzer que l'armée russe utilise alors
des armes nucléaires dites tactique ou
de faible puissance je vais pas vous
faire répéter ce que vous avez déjà dit
la dernière fois on va parler ensemble
il y a deux semaines vous dites quoi
vous dites c'est de la gesticulation
c'est quand même il y a peut-être un
peut-être une menace quand même à à
prendre en compte si Poutine faibli
comment vous l'analysez ça premièrement
effectivement prendre en compte oui bien
sûr ce serait totalement irresponsable
qu'un chef d'État ou de gouvernement ne
prennent pas en compte d'une menace ou
si terrible parce que encore une fois
une arme tactique c'est quand même pas
uniquement 10 fois une bombe
terre-robarrique c'est quand même
quelque chose de extrêmement puissant
c'est plusieurs dizaines de fois quand
même Hiroshima ou Nagasaki donc c'est
pas rien bon ça bien sûr
on imagine pas sur cette table nucléaire
ça reste de l'arme nucléaire donc quand
même soyons clair deuxièmement c'est
bien sûr un discours de propagande
qu'utilise Poutine d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps même depuis bien avant la
guerre et là je dis faisons attention
gardons la tête froide parce que il y a
quand même d'abord un discours pour
terroriser pour faire peur aux
populations et on voit aussi y compris
d'ailleurs chez nous en Europe en France
en particulier un certain nombre de
propagandises qui voilà vous voyez il a
l'arme nucléaire donc il faut s'asseoir
à la table de négociation il faut
discuter avec Monsieur Poutine il faut
céder et ça c'est une tactique que
Monsieur Poutine en 22 ans à très bien
utilisé et qui a fait que l'Occident a
toujours reculé depuis la Tchétchénie
mais surtout en Géorgie en 2008 en
Ukraine des gens 2014 après ce qui s'est
passé évidemment en Syrie à partir de
2015 ou les troupes sont arrivés en
automne 2015 donc dans ce pays et on a
toujours reculé parce qu'il y avait
toujours cette idée de cette menace même
quand elle n'existait pas d'ailleurs
parce qu'on Syrie on voyait mal de toute
manière la Russie utilisée c'est un donc
faisons très attention et surtout ne
jouons pas sur la peur parce qu'il y a
trop de gens je trouve qu'ils jouent sur
cette Emmanuel Macron ne cesse de
condamner l'invasion russe il continue
de s'asseoir et de discuter avec la
poutine donc pourquoi si ce n'est pas il
prend aussi en compte je pense Laetitia
mais on va pas répondre à cette question
parce qu'il nous reste assez peu de
temps moins de moins de 5 minutes et
j'aurais qu'on parle de de l'intérieur
du territoire russe tient une info de
cette fin d'après-midi le le fond de
lutte contre la corruption c'est
l'organisation de d'Alexa euh navalnick
et lui emprisonné et bien ce fond de
lutte contre une corruption annonce
rouvrir ses bureaux en Russie pour
lutter contre la mobilisation et et la
guerre en Ukraine à la lazarevac
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de des premiers
cercles deuxième cercle du pouvoir
autour de Vladimir Poutine et de et de
du soutien maintenu ou pas mais en fait
on est dit souvent que il est
représentant d'un certain clan qu'il est
passé indépendant que ça que justement
récemment on avait l'interview je pense
de une des personnes potagers qui
étaient anciennes amies de Poutine qui
qui n'est plus son ami il paraît qui
disait que il est que représentant d'un
certain groupe de gens qui ne le
laissent pas faire tout ce qu'il veut et
donc on mention le nombre des pas trop
cher et on ne pense même que son fils
peut-être peut être préparé comme une
remplaçants de petits au cas où il lui
arrive quelque chose et il paraît qu'il
est malade à quel point on a les malades
on ne sait pas mais il est toujours
accompagné par une foule des médecins
donc en fait tout ça c'est très très
très difficile à avoir les vrais
informations bien confirmées vous avez
bien de parler que justement bien
sourcer et bien vérifier c'est très très
difficile surtout quand il s'agit de
Kremlin qui qui veut faire tout pour
envoyer tout le monde mais en gros c'est
vrai qu'il y a tous ces
radicaux tout ces gens qui veulent la
guerre qui veulent reconstruire les
liens de soviétique et aller plus loin
si possible qui on a l'air d'influencer
beaucoup les décisions de Poutine et
donc est-ce que est-ce qu'ils arriveront
à
imposer encore leur volonté c'est
peut-être ça la grande question
d'aujourd'hui
ce sera pas forcément pour un pouvoir
plus favorable à l'Occident il peut y
avoir les les les durs ou les ou les
Aigles mais je vais vous dire moi très
égoïstement
ça ne me gêne pas moi je suis pas fait
pour réguler ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de la Russie je suis fait
pour
protéger mon pays et je me dis que si
quelqu'un arrive quel qu'il soit après
Poutine ça ne sera plus celui qui a
lancé cette guerre et donc la
négociation devrait devrait pouvoir être
plus facile je mets ça sous conditionnel
mais ce que je veux dire c'est que tout
sera plus facile que négociable avec
Poutine qui ne veut pas négocier et qui
est dans sa logique d'aller jusqu'au
bout vous comprenez un autre un extrême
pourrait très bien dire et ben écoutez
il a tout raté moi je vais vous
redresser la Russie mais pour ça il faut
qu'on discute pour pouvoir remettre la
Russie sur les bons rails un dernier mot
sur quand même cette cette je sais pas
quel terme employé cette épidémie cette
série de morts violentes qui frappe les
oligares qu'on a pris hier car au
responsable de la compagnie ferroviaire
nationale russe c'était suicidé je mets
des guillemets sur son balcon on
approche des 10 oligarques morts dans
des conditions violentes et douteuses
alors là aussi c'est très compliqué
Nicolas kenzer parce que voilà on manque
d'informations en manque d'informations
fiables sur cette
pire ça je n'y crois pas ça c'est aussi
un discours de propagande de ceux qui
veulent dire il faut quand même
conserver Poutine on sait qu'il est etc
mais on peut avoir effectivement des
gouvernements dangereux donc ne
relâchons pas tout de suite les
sanctions faisons très attention à la
manière dont on discute avec cette
future Russie merci beaucoup merci à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débat et à bientôt dans ce sens public